you're not going up anymore well i got
everything planned you'll have covetous
you know you you got to take a vaccine
and then you got to wait two weeks oh
let's get into this just gotta wait two
seriously
you thought you were just about to
travel free daddy yeah
wait what yeah i didn't know that you
thought you were allowed to just jump
the pond for freedom
yeah i thought you know what to europe i
know
europe's locked down they're opening now
but
in france a man can't wear a beret and
have a little there's that there's a new
variant in uk too you hear this fauci
came out and said this there's a new
variant yeah how long are we going to
buy in the fountain
no is there another one well according
to you know he's trying to keep his job
you know he's trying to
go did you get the vaccine yeah i did
yeah i did yeah i didn't want it but i
did i didn't either i
didn't want to just because it's like
nobody knows like i'm not not against it
i'm not an anti-vaxxer but you don't
know
like i was actually i was online for the
vax and i'm texting friend i was like 10
away
and like you know they keep calling and
i'm like yo should i be i was texting
comics going should i do this
i would text the comedians dick jokes
and strip malls
should i be doing this and and my
[ __ ] friends who were on the right
were like no
[ __ ] i had one friend go don't take that
homo juice
i had a friend tell me don't take that
home i go dude what
[ __ ] that is you'd be sucking
or it's going to help me no we're good
or you could really help them
unfortunately unfortunately i can't take
the homo juice
and i'm just on the phone what the [ __ ]
and then i had like friends who were on
the left
side of my hands yeah that's out of my
hands pappas who's like one of my
dearest guys
you think i should you think i should do
it he goes oh 100 it's it's science
and i actually took that as if he was a
medical doctor like he's vouching
yeah yes my recent my primary
research that i did you know from the
lab
would suggest when not telling dick
jokes my primary
research it's unbelievable it's so yeah
but stars is more my special
i like when people go i don't i don't
trust it man i don't try we've seen this
before
why have we yeah yeah i don't trust it
why not well well tripoli i you know
i could i do a podcast conspiracy social
club where i
sam triple hits me with conspiracies and
i debunk them and it's
just it turns into a shout fest every
time it's great but
tripoli's like vaccine shedding bro i'm
like
what do you mean he goes you can be near
somebody who has the vaccine
and it will render you infertile that's
the plan
population control i'm like is there any
measurable evidence how do you
i don't know how did he get there oh
dude it's called youtube
yeah we can go down the rabbit hole yeah
you can't it is
it is a little dicey how fast it rolled
out i mean operation warp speed was
great by trump but
it is a little weird how does that have
a month later like we have something i
was like oh i guess i'll take it i guess
but the side effects
sometimes can be pretty heavy but that's
that's for
look at chin got it oh i was [ __ ] up
dude oh you were last night
last night it just hits you when you
sleep did you take the johnson johnson i
took the modern day
that's what i got first team all my turn
up you got it you gotta we got modular
too madonna yeah i want that johnson
johnson just to mix it
oh daddy don't get that the one shot
yeah because it [ __ ] people up it gives
you like a third iron
you haven't heard this give your third
eye right yep
well i did hear actually i don't know if
you know this but like uh
like eight or nine very wealthy women in
connecticut took it and
all of them gave birth to black babies
they did
yeah oh i've heard that yeah yeah and so
they're enforcing diversity in the womb
you're doing the johnson
yeah but the problem is you gotta wait
two weeks now you gotta wait a month for
the johnson johnson two weeks for the
five so my whole trip is
my whole trip is in jeopardy i can't
believe you're you're a smart guy yeah
you're a smart guy i can't believe
nobody in your circle is like
hey dude you know you can't travel
international then back then well no you
i you question
i'm getting a vaccination with three
weeks to three almost four yeah three
weeks i have
um with three weeks to go i'm gonna say
okay
problem is even if i get the johnson
johnson i didn't know this they make you
wait a month you have to wait a month
here we go
see if it works meaning europe's going
to make you wait a month wait we have to
see if it takes because it's not because
now there's a low risk that it doesn't
take yeah but i've already had coverage
so that
that sometimes there's a loophole there
so i can get to so i can't go some if i
didn't have the modern shots and i want
to go to italy tomorrow i can't
you cannot go i did not know i did not
know
it's country by country like some of
them are lucy goosey and then
especially okay they tell you before you
book your ticket though
i did they didn't tell me yeah because
you weren't i went to hawaii and they
gave me a whole protocol of like rules
national deal yeah you don't think
internationally they would tell you what
you need to do before
you didn't tell me when i bought my
tickets i spent a lot of money on my
tickets
who booked your tickets me no you didn't
you've never
taken your life somewhere else man what
else
paul versus everybody uh the the cards
can be duplicated they're like people
are saying that the cards
are like being again it's like it's like
of course it is
like it's not laminated it's not it's
it's it's no it's
not mine right here have you seen it
like the
no but i might have to make up a call
it's just like yeah
it's like bigger than your wallet so it
won't fit it's it's
all right yeah you know what i got some
friends in the underworld
yeah especially if it's like they just
get a card and go ahead on this date and
then they but
they do give you a lot number there's a
lot number from the batch of the
vaccines where it traces back to where
you got it oh okay but they can figure
all that stuff out
yeah but but you know now and start you
know because june 15th
la opens because then the virus decides
to leave on the 15th
but all right like starbucks you go in
and it says if you're vaccinating you
don't have to
have to have a mass oh my god go and
have my mess and then they'll go are you
vaccinated i'm like oh you think people
are actually going to tell the truth
oh they're going to get they so they ask
it's the honor system yeah i'll get the
[ __ ] out of here
you're gonna lie did you have any side
effects uh
no i just had chill i had like a little
chills after the second dose yeah
first dose nothing no second dose i felt
like i was like getting a little sick i
i
was getting pissed dude yeah what the
[ __ ] i i don't have i have i had
antibodies a year later too
they said so they think i caught it
twice they thought oh really i had
covered twice
it's funny the way you told us you when
you found out you caught cove
i don't think nba player
yeah like rudy gobert let me know that i
was covered positive i was just he was
the first one he's the reason that big
went into lockdown he's the reason that
they couldn't have any fans
yeah he said he's like i can't smell
anybody else not smell her taste and i
went downstairs in my
you know laundry room i smelled fabri uh
put febreze in my face i couldn't smell
it
woke my wife up three o'clock in the
morning i can't smell [ __ ] she's like
what that's not even
and i was like yeah no it's a rudy
gobert the jazz just
she's like whoo i go [ __ ] where do
you go he's not
[ __ ] francis you got to be balls deep
in the basketballs
you might be a defensive player to here
defense player of the year yeah france
the fred's
i gotta be up with the kids